Pakistan is in
crisis the worst inflation in
Asia Mass
protests record Energy
prices and an uptake in Terror
attacks you're talking about a very very
important uh Regional uh Market Regional
power Pakistan's economy is sinking in
has no option but to seek a bailout
Pakistan was once hailed as a country
that could be an economic rival to its
neighbor India but it's falling further
and further
behind the nuclear armed country with
240 million people is living on the edge
of Ruin behind the scenes its military
is seen as holding sway over government
policies at the heart of it all Pakistan
is trapped in a cycle of borrowing that
appears to have no
end IMF can't let Pakistan think
Pakistan thinks it will be chaos and the
world can't afford this bigger
[Music]
kills now the economic situation in
Pakistan has gone from bad to worse
Pakistan's year- on-year inflation hit a
record level of
36.5% this is the highest have increased
in nearly 60
years Market
so Pakistani people are very concerned
at this point in time you can see people
are hopping on to boats risking their
lives to get to Europe somehow or
another people are borrowing money from
lone
sharks and we have seen last year at one
point 1/3 of Pakistan was flooded
completely and it led to see losses and
damages of $30
billion I will never forget the climate
related Carnage I saw lives homes livly
Woods schools hospitals all
obliterated it's it's expected that such
natural calamities will continue
happening and Pakistan does not have any
funds to deal with
it ahead of the general elections all
political parties have promised to take
on politically difficult reforms which
will help the country get on sustainable
Financial footing but none of them have
been able to do so in the
past um we we've been here before and we
have seen some of these bailouts
actually get halted over failure to meet
certain conditions it is very important
that Pakistan sticks to the commitments
under this uh program uh meaning don't
spend what you don't have be prudent on
tax collection one of the big problems
Pakistan has is very low tax to
GDP at the IMF we say if your tax to GDP
is below
15% you can't really quite function as
uh uh necessary to fund public
services and and the state
expenditures is Pakistan's debt
sustainable it is sustainable but it is
a borderline
sustainability Pakistan's inflows just
do not cover it its outflows Pakistan
does not export enough Pakistan doesn't
have enough foreign direct investment
coming in historically this Gap has been
filled by remittances bailouts and
direct injections of cash from China and
Saudi
[Music]
Arabia but we are short of his ideas but
we are short of his rules and laws that
are conducive to growth unfortunately we
don't understand that so we continue to
go to beg and borrow we continue to
build roads we continue to build all
these things which really don't not give
you quick
growth Nadim hak worked for the
international monetary fund for 24 years
now he's skeptical about the imf's
policies in Pakistan Pakistan is an IMF
addict and myf is a Pakistan
addict we are both locked in a death
dance the fault lies
within the country's political system is
fraught with instability with the
military directly ruling for almost half
of the nation's history and retaining
outsize influence even when
democratically elected governments took
power the entire status quo the entire
political status sces against me right
now Imran Khan's government tenure was
cut short when he was removed from power
in April of last year the government
that replaced him oversaw a Crackdown on
Khan's political party whose leaders are
now being tried in military
courts the caretaker prime minister has
previously said he will ensure Fair
punishment by law for those involved in
violent
protests we track down a member of Imran
Khan's political party the Pakistan t
insaf or PTI I mean can you tell the
audience why are you hiding at the
moment there's been a Crackdown on PTI
of the sort that unfortunately only
happens in countries like
Pakistan with a very clear and singular
objective of dismantling the party
if we continue to go down the same path
that we going if we think we can fix
this country without fixing the Civil
Service without fixing public sector
contracts without opening up to the free
market without political and economic
stability I don't want to imagine what
20 to 30 years down the line will look
like Pakistan has had a history of
violent Terror attacks since the Taliban
took over Afghanistan in
2021 the situation has got much
worse Pakistan's first priority is to
prevent encounter all terrorism from and
within
Afghanistan kakar's caretaker government
took over from Shabah Sharif in August
2023 we spoke to sharie's former
economic advisor we have to widen the
tax net we have to ensure that everyone
is paying their fair share of taxes our
tax to GDP uh ratio is far too low um
responsible privatization is is is the
need of the hour we can no longer afford
as a country uh to continue bleeding uh
in the manner uh that we have on the
account of uh the state-owned
Enterprises in all this time Pakistan
has been living beyond its
means all of this is creeping in it is
impacting
people that includes people like janze a
stock analyst he has decided to leave
Pakistan for
good everyone I know either they have
moved out of the country or they are
desperately looking to move out I was
Kinder driven by the economics
uncertainity the rapid prr depreciation
uh rampant inflation and uncertain
political environment of the country
even though I had a very comfortable um
job I decided this this was not uh what
I want to uh go through every day
right life in Pakistan will continue to
be dominated by one institution the
Pakistan
Army it has been a constant throughout
decades and continues to exert influence
from behind the scenes some analysts say
military interference stops overall
progress but then others argue it's the
only institution that really can get
things done in Pakistan
hope seems to be running out for most
pakistanis but not for all we have to
work together to convince our best and
brightest that they have a future here
that that we we are intent on and are
doing everything we can to make things
easier for
[Music]
them
Pakistan will make
it the question is
[Music]
when
oh